yesterday was the anniversary of jackie
robinson breaking the color barrier
today we honor him here at citizens bank
park both the cardinals and the phillies
wearing the number 42 across the board
zach eflin 13 innings so far an era of
3.46 facing edmond as edmond on the
first pitch grounds it up the middle
that's an 11-game hitting streak for
tommy edmond well you might as well get
it out of the way right there's paul
goldschmidt the average at 234. swinging
a mess
effluent wins the battle one out here in
the first inning
and here comes the birthday boy nolan
aronado is a 30th birthday
ground ball to third bone to second for
one over to first in time a double play
that
is a nice way to start the ball game
we go to the bottom of the first carlos
martinez this year has been a struggle
for him last few years he's been
hurt more by the long ball reese hoskins
hitting 261.
there's a swing and a miss
and there's two away
slider right here didn't really break
kind of backed up and best pitch and
worst pitch in all of baseball back up
slider
here's bryce harper over his last seven
and he launches one
into deep rights
and it's caught
tommy edmond up against the screen with
the catch
nice play by a second baseman how does
that ball stay in the ballpark cold
night
balm hitting 233.
ground ball toward the hole backhanded
by deyoung and he has no play he looked
like he slipped a little bit and that'll
be an infield hit for alec ball first
hit of the day for the phillies so a man
on for dd gregorius grump all right side
and off the glove of carpenter into
shallow right field balm is on his way
to third he'll get there
first and third with one man down
and so now gene segura
fly ball left center field going back on
it is carlson
i don't know if he sees it he doesn't
see it it drops in for a face hitting
shallow center bone scores sigour to
second it'll be an rbi double
one nothing phillies
that's three plays in one inning
that should have produced outs and it
produces three straight hits
and he's looking you can't see it but
you know he's not telling anyone he
can't see it he just drifted back i mean
that's when you got to tell someone you
know hey i don't have it i don't have it
they're now going to walk mickey moniak
intentionally now the bases are loaded
for zach f1 who's all for three but zach
certainly can handle the bat
inside did that hit him it did it raised
his thigh
it's going to force in a run it's two
nothing phillies
yadi or molina reacted almost
immediately because he could hear it
and see it probably yeah martinez threw
his arms up and then yachty looked in
the dugout because you know they were
asking him did it hit him it hit him
yeah he shook his head yes
well now make him pay
make him pay more two runs in
and andrew loops it to right field
that's going to drop in for a hit one
run is in rounding third is moniak
heading home he'll score two run single
for andrew mccutchen it ends at old for
14 and the phillies lead it four nothing
a nice little piece of hit by andrew
mccutchen he didn't he was making sure
he didn't roll over one and hit a
grounder to shortstop like he did his
first hit back
just
punches it into right field look at him
he knows
[Laughter]
well the base is loaded for bryce harper
really make this a big inning four spot
for the phils here with still only one
out
line driving center field that's gonna
split the gap it's gonna get cut off at
the warning track one run is in
mccutchen will head home too and harford
a second it's a two-run double
it's six nothing you were right on john
[Applause]
good things happened when you put the
ball play tom when you look how this
inning got started a slip
a missed turn a missed fly ball
strikeout so that none of those plays
happen
you put the ball in play you give your
team a chance of course bryce
always aggressive on the base pass
philly's lead at six nothing as we move
to the top of the fourth inning swinging
a miss or that slider away
either one
did the trick goldschmidt strikes out
for the second time the two out there's
yada yada molina
swagger to miss
two strikeouts of the inning for f wood
he's retired seven consecutive hitters
harper with a double that brought in two
he's driven in six this year
and goes the other way it's well hit
dylan carlson back and with room to make
the catch
what a great game zach keflan will go
back to work here in the fifth inning
there's a swing at a fly ball to harper
to his left he goes he'll make the catch
and just like that effluent the
lickety split fifth inning one two three
go the cards
and that's now ten in a row sat down by
eflin we're going to the bottom of the
fifth grigorius an infield hit a run
scored and a pop-up to
short and that pitch has popped up
ornato and fouled territory 11 in a row
set down by carlos martinez we head to
the sixth first and second for nolan
ornato swing and a miss he got him
five strikeouts for effluent
no runs two hits and two men left
zach f won six innings of scoreless
baseball so far that'll bring up the
shortstop paul deyoung
in a swing and a miss
he got him with the slider he's used
that slaughter so well tonight six
strikeouts very few curveballs tonight
for zach epwood
at a one two three seven bryce is on
base with a walk with one out here in
the seven
real muto who is old for two
coming up
no one is drilled to deep left field is
it fair foul it's a fair ball inside the
poll home run
jt real muto his second home run of the
year it's eight nothing phillies
97
career home runs
he drilled it
now we've seen so many balls get held up
the couple
that's the way you got to hit him out of
here you got to hit him on the line and
jt just absolutely smoked one down the
left field line
we're on to the so the run rate second
is carlson now justin williams who has
flied to left and grounded out to second
that is well hit out to deep left and
it's gone
justin williams his first home run
an opposite field home run a two-run
shot justin williams gets saint louis on
the board
and that will be a moment he'll never
forget that first home run
he'll get that baseball first ever home
run justin williams in the big leagues
roman quinn walks that puts runners on
first and second and mccutcheon strolls
to the plate
over toward third again it hits the bag
and goes down the left field line segura
around third heading for home quinn to
third rbi single for mccutchen 9-2
phillies
cuts with his third rbi of the night
came in with two
he has three in today's game
this is john nagowski
pinch hitting for matt carpenter with
two outs in the top of the ninth
line drive one that's caught out of the
air by d.d gregorius will throw it
across the diamond in time
and the ball game is over
the phillies come home
and win for the sixth time in seven
games here at citizens bank park
they win it nine to two